citizens of the reject Nation we got ourselves
an official trailer for Dune two John number
four how are you I'm good I'm all spiced up
and ready to go how are you g be careful we
gotta be mindful of the censorship YouTube
is one of those days we can't talk about the
science fiction spice and taking it or else it
might sound suggestive I don't want to suggest
I have the ability to chart plots through
space and time thank you for being mindful
ladies and gentlemen if you're excited
for Dune two leave a like on this video
um fear is never any killer ladies and
gentlemen before we go to this trailer
I have to give a massive massive thank you
to everyone who has already bought tickets
we have sold a bunch for the event that I am
doing with John campia and Christian harloff
this coming Sunday May 7th at five o'clock P.M
Flappers comedy in Burbank so many of you ever
bought tickets already see a couple months back
we United to do a live show in honor of Ant-Man
and the WASP quantumania talked about it but
mainly we got to interact with fans who were
there during the show and after the show it was
one of the best moments of my YouTube career so
we thought we'd do it again for Gardens
the Galaxy Vol 3. it's a movie that all
three of us really loved so I'm excited to be
talking about excited to meet all of you who
are going to be there if you can come in person
we still got some tickets available that would
be amazing to have you there but if you can't
come in person we also have pay-per-view links
as well so anywhere from around the world
come and watch thank you guys so much again
there's links in the description box and pin
comment let's see this trailer for don't dos
breathtaking these iMac shots if
you dive in you can't reach the
bottle you dive in yes it's called
swimming I don't I don't believe you
crazy kids in the shadows of arracus lie many
secrets is that Florence lady Jessica in the pod
it's a good line the end of House of treaties
the father didn't believe in Revenge [Music]
what if parallel treaties were still alive yeah
[Music]
oh she's spiced up have you ever
had a dream about your first ride
don't try to impress anyone
ride that worm do we we
don't know that these simple
God damn wow
nothing fancy I understand [Laughter]
ride the worm
yes come what deep [Music] hello
God butcher
[Music] we gave them something to hope for that's
not home oh [__] she upgraded
man with a knife chip and shatter
oh damn man rise to your mantle [Music]
wow what a beautiful trailer I heard this whole
thing you shot an iMac that's the entire thing
is Sean and IMAX I saw the first one at a
regular theater uh second one on on Dolby
and then the third one on on real IMAX and I'm a
IMAX Enthusiast this was one of the most beautiful
movies I've seen on IMAX to see that this is
going to be entirely filmed on IMAX and to have
this like all-out War vibe to it I'm very very
very excited for it because I remember like the
for when the first trailer for the last one came
out and people who weren't familiar with the book
I was really under the impression like they're
trying to like advertise the action in this
trailer but it's probably gonna be like a real
slow dreddy kind of movie and then it came out
and that's what it was for the most part I mean
it's still gorgeous and beautiful but I and I
love the hell out of the movie I thought it was
amazing this one I I really feel like we're gonna
get a lot of great action as well uh it just
seems like so many of the sequences of what
we were building upon from the last one to hear
the rise of Paula tradies and uh I like to call
them the fry man that's right I have my ways of
remembering them the Benny and the Jets this is
what I call the better Jets that's great the
Kiwi hash browns is the quizzots the hadoukens
is what I call them yeah definitely so I'm like
this that's how you get there I think the most
impressive things that I I think can easily be
taking for granted is the fact that they did
shoot this later they didn't shoot this back to
back but it is meant to be treated as one gigantic
film this feels like it was shot back to back just
from the way everyone looks like this doesn't look
at all that there was a gap in filming yeah it
really does look cohesive which is interesting too
because uh Denny Villeneuve I think said he wanted
to use like all new stuff and new locations and
new everything for this movie and and two he kind
of echoed that sentiment that you just brought up
which is the first movie being much more of
a contemplative building experience than this
being sort of a more Epic War Story I mean that
definitely communicates from this trailer and I
just love the way that yeah you have the growth
of the Paula tradies story you know rising to
lead these people out of uh the desert basically
out of their relegation they're called fry men's
the fry the fry guys but two just to look at the
new characters too and I like I love the take on
fade rotha here because I think a lot of people
just know the The Sting with his wild hair and
his little gold diaper to have Austin Butler to
have Elvis now Ascend to this role and be sort of
like the anti-politrates I think is a really fun
thing and and a sort of like complete opposite
from what you're expecting of Austin Butler at
this exact moment and then Florence Pew too is a
great choice uh I think for lady erolon and I'm
curious to see how they attack that part of the
story because in the book she isn't really a care
like she shows up at one point she doesn't really
speak aside from like these little asides that
open up every chapter with historical context so
it seems like they have a lot of room to you know
did you actually finish the book I'm pretty close
and yeah every chapter opens up with a piece of
context to the overall story delivered by her it's
almost like you're reading a history compiled by
her character and so uh they're gonna have to take
some creative license in realizing her here she's
already got more dialogue I think than she does in
the book and uh and I wonder if they'll show like
you know sort of the ruling home world and I think
Christopher Walken's her Dad too so like that's
gonna become a pretty important you know side of
the story it's not Chinese what do you want to
my daughter Austin Butler is the brother of the
Dave Bautista character so I'm I'm very curious
to see how they interact and and you know what
their chemistry becomes like if they have much
of it in the story I mean well there was such a
build up to Dave Bautista as well uh from the last
movie and we we don't see a ton of him here but I
thought he'd be a little more prevalent obviously
Josh Brolin is back which is exciting to see that
he is able to survive this looks like he's lived
quite a life since then you know you also have
Rebecca Ferguson lady Jessica gosh that's an easy
name to remember uh lady Jessica who looks like
she got a Benny and the Jets upgrade oh she has
ascended herself she's been on that spice boy I
mean what is she trying to get high up with the
bed of jestery trying to attend more power don't
tell me don't ruin it yeah I mean at very least
she's trying to gain that sight that allows you to
see through time and plot you know charts through
the Galaxy and there was one shot in here where
it was kind of reminding me of uh because in the
last movie Paul had to fight with the knife uh
the knife fight with the fremin and then yeah it
looked like he was going to shed was that was he
gonna show down with with Austin Butler yeah I
think so he and uh fade Ralph uh because because
fade Ralph is set up to be like the harkonan
version of Paul basically he's just like the
anti-paul oh gosh so he's just this like vile
opportunistic figure who yeah probably will have
to duel with him before the movie is out I love it
I love to see it it all looks fantastic and we're
actually gonna get more Zendaya of course because
I remember when the the second time I watched it
when they finally got to Zendaya towards the end
of the movie there was like one person in the
audience who just screamed they went finally like
because they advertised her all over the trailer
and then she barely was in the movie yeah but
we're obviously going to get a lot more of her
uh but yeah I'm excited for it guys what did you
think about this Dune dose trailer leave your
thoughts down below be sure to subscribe leave
a like and hey uh before we go thank you again
for uh everyone who bought tickets ready for the
show listens to the patron of the day shout out
Tyler Hague Tyler if you were a sand worm
I would love to ride you through the desert
I feel like we would have some great travels
getting through all that dirt and also being
able to cuddle up with you when it gets too
cold at night discovering all kinds of Hidden
Treasures primarily spice we could find together
oh man you and I on spice together we would have
a ball of a Time the kind of visions and love
making we would ultimately end up doing and
not remembering in the morning would be well
worth it Tyler you know it would be worth it
anyway you know what do I really need to say
more man you're perfect I can't wait to ride
you in the desert my friend get that worm
boy get that quiz that's Tyler Rock [Music]